hi toh I'm going to get started my name
is Matt libo I'm from the partners
fertilized medicine i left my own
medicine here as well as bring ones
hospital and harvard medical school i'm
going to talk today a little bit about
you know an exome sequencing it and our
experience with it as a clinical
laboratories so really the the way that
Exim Jim sequencing can be thought of is
is really a component of the larger
landscape so if we think about it gene
panels are very small usually around 50
to 100 genes a very small component of
the overall genome medical acts so much
i'll mention a little bit is sort of
what but clinically relevant genes are
that we have most probably more in the
order of for the five thousand genes may
be about 10 to 12 million base pairs the
full exome as everyone knows it's closer
to 60 million bases 22,000 genes and the
entire genome about three billion bases
but five percent of which is how to
conserve and one to send which is the
coding exons and if we think about sort
of the testing landscape today that it
really is separated into sort panel
testing and affects women genome testing
and so panel testing is really well
clearly well-defined genes and what we
aim for their is really high coverage
and completeness and so we're interested
in completely covering every single base
within our defined roi exome and genome
sequencing is a little different a lower
coverage obviously the completeness is
less than a hundred percent and it's not
usually filled in and it's really right
now for more diagnostic Odysseys or
complex overlapping phenotypes up what
I'm here to talk to you a little bit
about is when you're thinking about
exome and genome sequencing it really is
in the standpoint of development and
testing very similar to NGS panels if
you think about the testing workflow
testing workflow really is the same
regardless of which of the methods that
you're doing so genetic tests will come
in you'll be accessioning of that test
on the wet lab case management portion
of it for pretty much all of today's
testers and bioinformatics
even Sanger sequencing to terschelling
today has our firm attic pipelines help
automate that process is curation of the
data to determine what sort of as
pathogenic will end up on their portal
won't there's drafting of the report and
then we'll sign out to report delivery
and really again this is the same
regardless of whether you're doing X own
genome sequencing or clinical target
panels and similarly the test
development stage is actually the same
whether you're doing eczema genome
sequencing so the way that we tend to
think of test development is there
really is some development where there's
an optimization stage but where you're
really learning your ass a learning what
you're doing figuring out what the
appropriate analyses are and actually
understanding sort of what the strategy
for that testing will be and doing some
optimization of that whole process after
that you really then get into the
validation stage I'll talk a little bit
about our validation of our exome and
genome in a couple slides really what
you're looking for is sort of the
reproducibility the robustness and how
accurate your assay is I'm important
here to sort of include different
variant I so being able to understand
how well it can detect indella
substitutions seeing beads if that's
what you're asking is actually doing or
actually understanding sort of common
pathogenic variants and your ability to
do that after it's more focused on sort
of genotyping tech pathway but again
this is sort of the the similar process
for exome and genome sequencing as it is
for clinical targeted panels just sort
of a broader scope of the testing you're
doing and maybe even a limited set of
samples that you can work on due to the
cost of actually Union sequencing so
again the exome and genome development
again is similar to the panel testing
one of the things that it but I want to
point out is that traditionally labs
sort of bundled their validation process
from beginning to end what's really
becoming more recently if you're having
evident that you can actually separate
the technical validation from sort of
some of the more downstream
bioinformatics validation by technical
validation I mean sort of how well the
platform is performing and the
reproducibility polls enter an intra run
variability of the platform and really
how well that that platform can produce
what you're expecting it produced and
the separate end is that the
bioinformatics component where if you're
taking that data and actually doing some
the alignment and bearing calling
coverage annotation filtration whatever
you may be doing for your downstream
steps I'm actually validating that whole
process and the ability to produce
results at the end and you can actually
sort of decouple these two things and
and the ability the ability to actually
have this decoupling enables you to sort
of upgrade one component first together
component without having to do sort of
this poll validation and everything so
it's really important to to start
thinking about this when you're
implementing it that you can sort of do
again this technical validation versus
this more the further downstream
bioinformatics validation I'll talk to
you probably a little bit more in the
bottom product validation side today
than the technical side but it's when
you're thinking about how to evaluate
the platform there are specific things
that would go into that as well so one
of the things that I'm going to talk
about again in our talk is in our exome
data we've work to sort of produce a
more clinically relevant X home and I'm
going to be mentioning the words medical
exone I just want to sort of let you
guys know what that was so the medical
exome was a collaboration between
various thumb one of the directors at
our laboratory as well as her colleagues
at Emory and chop and the goal of the
medical exclamation that they put
together was to really define a set of
clinically relevant genes and then to
enhance sort of exome content to make
sure those jeans were really well
captured and really well covered so
often times they are sorted by specific
exons that aren't captured their
specific genes that really were part of
the capture kid or there's the
transcripts that were part of the
capture kit I'm the goal was to sort of
look at what was underperforming and
then boost those regions to really get
higher completeness and higher coverage
of the clinically relevant chains which
is can be very useful sort of clinical
exome sequencing and so this is sort of
a pilot that we use the results from
sort of determine what or to use this
this enhanced exome kit to really drive
our further processes and I will sort of
mention a little bit the results from
this although I won't show the
difference between the older and newer
one but we were able to actually get
much higher coverage a much higher
completeness for the
the relevant genes you to move approach
so when you're going through your again
exome and genome pipeline and even some
your NGS pipelines your first step is
from the bottom attics components of the
alignment variant calling annotation
processes and so just as a brief
overview of what we're doing for our
genome cases we're using a modified bwa
gatk approach to really paralyzed this
and to reduce the computation time down
to something that is a little bit more
manageable and just to give you guys a
rough size what we're doing we're using
600 million paired-end reads it's about
an average depth of 40 x + 95
completeness 95% completeness over the
entire genome our excellent pipeline is
a little bit more standard since the
processing time view x little less so
for here we have about 70 million
paired-end reads average depth is at
least 150 x was a little bit higher and
because of this medical exome initiative
that we did it has coverage there we're
actually getting closer to 200 x for
disease panels when we're looking at
known disease panels that have clinical
relevance in our current pipeline
identify right now snv's and small in
dells although we are working on
including CNVs and other other
structural variant calls in addition
before snv's and small in dells we're
getting about five million baron calls
pre quality filtration part genome and
120,000 variant calls pre quality
filtration for our x own so it is a
large number of variants that were sort
of sifting through and I'll talk a
little bit about the filtration a little
bit later on the toxin so when you're
thinking about how to validate this is
actually a few different good sources up
there for validation and again
validation of exome and genome
sequencing although it does fit the mold
of sort of any laboratory developed test
there are some caveats because the cost
of sequencing you can't really do the
breadth of individuals but you might
want to and also you can't necessarily
validate all those variants that you're
finding if you do the brats of
individuals and so really a lot of the
way that exome and genome validation is
done is focusing on specific samples and
understanding the the accuracy across
that sample in
multiple different regions and so the
the sample that most people tend to you
today is na 128 78 from the cordial
samples and so there's a few different
initiatives and have tried to look at
what are really known well known very
well carry variance from this sample so
the first is that we get our end
elevation of CDC and what this includes
is variant calls that were confirmed
confirmed via orthogonal technology
oftentimes Sanger sequencing by
submitting laboratories and most of
laboratories that submitted to the
guitar on project or clinical
laboratories that really did look at
confirmation of these variants across
multiple different technologies we
actually use a set that we did upload to
the sea to get our own project and the
one that I'm going to talk about today
for our laboratory is about for a little
less than 450 Sanger variants or
variants for anyone to 87 a that we've
confirmed with Sanger sequencing and so
we actually know both all the places
that we have variant calls and other
places where with homozygous reference
we can get an understanding of both
sensitivity and specificity for these
regions the other initiative that is
really well establishes a genome in the
bottle from NIST and really this is
looking at integrated variant calls from
multiple different technologies multiple
different platforms and what they've
been able to do is create a high
confidence set of variant calls and
we've actually tested this on our data
it actually performs very well in
comparison with our Sanger data and they
have a much broader region obviously
than the limit region we have assigned a
follow-up this is another great tool a
great data set to be able to actually
start thinking about sensitivity and
specificity measures for your excellent
genome sequencing and then finally gk is
sort of a website that uses the nest
data set so you can sort of automate the
process of doing some of the analyses if
you're interested in doing that so this
is the validation results of our genome
sequencing our exome sequencing was
pretty much the same really we had again
a little over 400 a little as forty
fifty Sanger confirm variants across
about 700 kb of sequence and based upon
our genome sequencing NR exome
sequencing we were able to attend
by all of those I think in our exome
sequencing we missed one variant that
was in strc which is one of the most
highly repetitive genes in the genome
model is called two other packets in
that one as well so we actually aren't
getting very good accuracy and results
from this data and actually if we would
think about the specificity we're
actually not getting that many false
positives and so we we initially had a
fair number of false positives when we
look at it but most of those have really
poor quality so by establishing specific
quality metrics in this case we use
tissue strand bias and the quality by
Jeff my dress from gatk we're actually
really able to reduce the normal false
positives that would end up in a final
data set when we can get very similar
results with our exome data and we're
actually able to use the same thresholds
for exome data that we're using for our
genome data so shows are these
thresholds are actually fairly robust
for the platform and for the the tools
and software is that we're using finally
another way you can sort of think about
how well your did before is performing
is to do concurrency checks with other
data sets and so the thousand genomes
data is necessarily a gold standard data
set but if you compare your results to
some of the thousand genomes data and
get an idea of how well correlated you
are obviously the higher concordance
rate between the two data sets the more
confidence you might have and sort of
what you were able to do and so we
actually had fairly high concordance
especially in SMBs and this is wolf sort
of just gentleman cordage was the
variant called and also what was the
zygosity of that also be able to get
concordance levels of close to a hundred
percent at least 98 99 percent for both
though so it's a little bit lower for 4
in valves again so again we also were
able to do this comparison to the missed
high quality data set and so what we're
looking at here is our sensitivity and
our positive value analyses against the
NIST data set and specifically we're
looking at the entire exome versus just
the this medical XO up about four to
five thousand genes you can see we
actually get very similar results in
terms of our sensitivity analysis and
are probably pretty good value and you
can see that this is another great way
to think about how you can validate your
data set
using this tool and and it really does
give you the ability to a much broader
standpoint across a much wider range of
jeans and maybe you have data for to
really be able to start doing the
comparisons to get the accuracy of your
data of your own technology so this was
a validation of the platforms and the
one of the things we do in addition to
sort of understanding how well we're
calling variants understanding how
complete our and eyesight is and so one
thing that's also important to do is
sort of a coverage analysis so this is a
little bit more than just sort of what's
the average coverage across your region
it's really understanding how well
things are covered so for instance you
might think about the base level
coverage is one of the metrics that we
look at is the percent of bases across
certain regions that are callable so
above get thresholds have low coverage
that have zero coverage of that format
my qualities that other different
thresholds may go into this as well you
can also think about the exon level
coverage and so traditionally people
tend to think of jeans or how well cover
they are it's at certain amplicon the
sort exxon so we tend to think of that
example how the percent of the exon that
it out of Kabul level so how many exons
do we have where hundred percent of the
exon is at 20 x for x 0 more or eight
extra genome on that sort of measure or
how many of them are like 75 percent of
the the bases in that Exxon or at a
callable level the console thinking
about gene level coverage and so from
gene level coverage perspective it's
really the percent of gene that is is
fully covered so you know you're really
good data the percent of genes that are
partially covered and can break the
partial coverage down into different
metrics or the percent of genes that are
not covered at all they know that you're
never going to get data for and that you
can have really trouble with in terms of
your clinical assay and really you can
do this company analysis across multiple
different ro eyes and I'll show you the
next slide that we've done this across
different sort of X omorrow eyes and as
well as to feed sub-panels
so this is an example of our coverage a
that's what you were looking at the
exxon level coverage data sorry that
didn't might not be pretending that well
for you guys but really what we're
looking at is the percent of exons
within these different region of
interests that are fully covered a 20x
coverage for our exome data or at our at
lower coverage so the dark blue is the
the exons that are fully covered under
side covered at 20 x you can see that we
look at our roi the first thing we're
looking at here is the exone plus or
minus 15 bases a second one to see the
full XL in touch mines two bases then
the third one is the medical x own which
is again the regions that we enhanced
coverage for and then the following five
are sort of more disease sub-panels
including ACMG and settle clients list
you can see here even for the exome data
we're getting pretty complete coverage
across most axons we're getting complete
coverage across the most exons at
greater than eighty percent ninety
percent level for our full exome as we
go to the things that are more
clinically relevant this is really
covering closer to ninety-seven
ninety-eight percent and see that it
makes it feasible and it makes it much
more complete to think about actually
doing more target panel sequencing
actually offer back some data so that's
sort of the the validation process of
exome and genome sequencing and the next
step in the process is is really to
think about what you do once you have
that data and so once you have sort of
bearing calls that you trust and I
believe a real the way that we approach
this is to do a really broad annotation
of bearings and there's multiple
different software tools that are
available at listed a few key everyone's
interested we use a few of these tools
and some of our own in-house tools to
annotate variance with a greater than
100 different bearing features will call
them these features include nomenclature
the type of aryan functional prediction
to a wolf conservation frequency my over
to do that sort of thing and also
presence or absence databases and what
the database is my totem so we also
annotate for instance using clint bar we
then upload all of these patients very
in the annotate variants to our internal
genomic data repository which enables us
to sort of filter based on quality
metrics on patient variants on different
annotations to really produce a smaller
subset of parents that we would look at
during our exome and genome sequencing
process so one of the things that that's
important to consider when doing x-women
genome sequencing is that most of the
time you'll have someone who comes in
with some sort of phenotype and one of
the first things you do especially if
you have Singleton's you don't have
parents as you might need to limit it
based on really what that their diseases
and so one of the first things to do is
actually try to identify to release gene
lists that are there in a tech driven
and so there's some issues here there's
really not that great ontology available
and there's not great sort of gene
disease associations that are really
well-curated and so in the future there
will be a lot more tools out there that
enable you to sort of do this but right
now it's a it's a little bit harder to
sort of create these intuitive driven G
lift and it's oftentimes a little bit
more manual there are a few sort of
software tools out there that that can
help you with this so there are some
ways to sort of capture structure
phenotype data so it's you know tips and
dubious I will consult all sort of do
this and then there's two latina mizer
that can sort of help you take this and
select specific genes of interest
although there's a lot more work that
needs to be done in this area to sort of
automate this process but this is one of
the the key components and right now is
probably a key time component as well is
to really determine which genes if you
have a sort of phenotype driven gene
lists that you're going to focus on in
order to do the filtration so again once
you have sort of your phenotype or
Eugene strategy that you want to do or
you maybe have a genetic strategies you
look for de novo variants or couple
hundred I guess we looking for sort of
homozygous variants for consent latest
families once you sort of have that
strategy established then you can do
this filtering to get to sort of smaller
set of bearings you want to manually
review and we do this sort of against
our genomic data repository we do this
using SQL queries right now although
we're hoping to sort of make
too much more you I friendly our
analysis in GCS and there are sort of
multiple software solutions that do work
in the space some of them do both
annotation infiltration and I've listed
a subset of them there that could
provide ability for something good to do
this in the future or do this now it
should say but in their own laboratory
so once you have the list of variants
that are really filtered down it really
is important to dive into these and
actually do a thorough assessment of
this and so really we do a manual
assessment of each of the variants that
end up in our filter list and we died
down to the ones that are most likely
clinically relevant into a much more
expanded varying assessment tool which
I'll talk about next I'm one of the
things that's important to consider when
you're doing this this filtration which
is a little bit unique to genome and
excellent sequencing and a little
different than traditional target panels
you actually then have to do a gene
assessment often to really determine how
good the evidence is for this gene
Disease Association and so one of the
additional components here is we
actually have a process that we have in
house but still there's another time
component where you have to think about
is this gene and this disease
association really well-established or
is it really just one family that was
mentioned once in the literature a long
time ago and so really how likely is it
that even if the variant seems to be
pathogenic that it really would be
pathogenic for specific disease so again
we mentioned we have a very an
assessment tool that we use in house on
that that can be made available to
others if they're interested but really
the goal for us was to produce a very
robust well validated way to clinically
interpret our bare hands so we have an
excel-based tool that we use it takes in
a lot of annotated information presented
in a way four thousand GCS to really
look at an interactive and integrated
view enables us to really do this in
depth dive into the variants that we
think might have the most clinical
relevance this is an example of a a
screenshot from it as well a paper that
we published last year and sort of talks
a little bit about it again this is sort
of one in one page of multiple tabs that
we look at but the conservation to have
to understand
from the functional prediction tools how
will conserve or how likely to this
video I terious and then we sort of
present this again in a summary view
where we then determined sort of our
evidence section that would go on to
report so this is a example of the
evidence section or the evidence that we
associate with the variant that we would
actually add on the end of the we add on
to one of our reports and this process
is actually very important so if you
think about variants that have been
determined to be pathogenic or not in
the database these are the variants that
have been determined to be that were
called pathogenic previously in a
database and after we did thorough
evaluation of them what actually was the
past unity of them and it turns out that
only about three percent of variants
that that were called pathogenic in some
of these databases did after manually
reviewed we feel like actually met the
past initially clicked criteria to be
included on a report so again it's very
important to to go and dive a little bit
more deeply into a lot of these variants
because the databases that are currently
available really are as high-quality as
as hopefully will be so again this is
sort of quickly what is is what we do so
we look at the variant annotation we use
a bunch of stuff to do our variant
classification and for genome and exome
sequencing is actually a little
different if we only report likely
pathogenic and pathogenic variants and
then occasionally we will report a small
set of us is that really seemed relevant
for this individual patient but might
not be for another patient so that's a
small set of variants that we end up
reporting on our on our clinical reports
and this an example is sort of what our
clinical excellent report is we try to
create a one-page summary that puts in
all the relevant information including
the variance and relevant to the disease
and any sort of internal findings that
we just identified and then in
subsequent pages we do the more detailed
information of really why we classify
this variant in that manner and really
what the disease information for this
individual variant is so this is sort of
a way to sort of presents a one page
view of the overall results and then
further go into a lot more detail if the
Commission wants to understand sir why
we came
to these conclusions in the beginning
and this is something that we've
developed sort of in contact with the
Med see project which I'll talk about
next but give you an idea of sort of
what we aim to get back to to clinicians
so they can actually have an
understanding in a much more simplified
manner or fourth of planning that we
found or one of the things we've also
been adding is sort of a supplementary
coverage report and so if someone has
came in for specific phenotype and we
really did when week's phenotype driven
gene list analyses it's really important
to be able to let that clinician know
how well things were covered or not
covered so that way in case there was a
gene that is really relevant to the
disease that was not covered you can
flag that and sort of let them know that
although we did look for the subset of
genes there's one critical gene you
weren't able to cover it so you may need
to do additional follow-up testing if
you still a suspect for this this sort
of gene may be responsible for this
patients with these so we've been using
our exome and genome sequencing
obviously clinically but also to support
a few different clinical trials and so
I'm going to go through quickly the
couple different clinical trial to that
we're really looking at so the first one
is the med seek project which is a
randomized controlled project or looking
with patients with disease the stifling
this manner target myopathy that are
presenting to cardiologists as well as
healthy individuals that are just coming
into their regular primary care
physician for routine care when we do
sort of us played between people who get
standard care and people who get
standard care plus a genome report but
then looking at the outcomes from
delivering back the genome report and
we're looking at the outcomes including
medical review for the people who got
genome sequencing and people about a
regular standard of care for both the
healthy arm and the disease arm and for
this one again we're using a filter in
strategy we were looking at just
incidental findings but it's really
large it's a no findings list so it's
all we really look at all things I've
been previously determined to be
pathogenic using HTML in vonore own
internal database or loss of function
variants across the medical exomes that
we then go and review
we also return pharmacogenomic variants
and blood groups information in the
context of the Med seek project and then
sort of look at again what the how the
patients how the conditions deliver this
information how the patients respond to
the information and actually if we think
about is it's even if we have a really
large expanded incidental findings this
we're really not finding that much so
we've done about 40 these cases so far
but for the first seven cases that I
present here we actually only find one
disree variants 123 incidental finding
variants per individual and most of
these tend to be carried Arkansas a few
of them sort of tend to be dominant and
dealing disorders over finding so really
is a very small amount of variants that
end up being returned and a much smaller
amount that we actually initially
expected from the on-site the other
project that we're supporting is the
baby sea project was you can doing a
similar project specifically looking at
sequencing and the newborns newborn
sequencing sort of the context of genome
sequencing and so what we're doing here
is where again doing a randomized
control project that we're looking at
NICU infants that are randomized to
either receive the genome sequencing or
standard care again healthy newborns
that are that are either going to do
standard of care or genome sequencing
and so this is a project that is just
getting started now hopefully we'll have
some results in the near future be able
to present but it's something we're
really interested in pursuing what's our
along with our clinical lab sizes how we
going to stand really the effects of
genome and exome sequencing in a
clinical context by doing these sort of
randomized control studies so what's
that I'd like to sort of sank a lot of
people that are work with your partner
personalized medicine I think with a few
minutes left we can take any questions
that you guys can submit through the Q&A
session well thank you for listening
all right so I guess I don't have any
questions coming in but if you guys are
if you guys think of any questions as
your follow-up and you want to email me
feel free it's just m LD be 0 at
partners org I might be happy to sort of
share some of the tools that we've
developed or talking with our processes
and then our experiences here I've
hardness torchlights noticing and
establishing 2x I'm genome sequencing in
the clinical context all right thank you